let's talk about some neural tube
defects when the anterior part of the
neural tube fails to form there could be
defects like craniodicaskis this is
severe with the brain and the cranial
World failed to form there is no skin
covering and there is a contiguous bony
defect of the cervical spine
then there is anencephaly with the baby
is born without the part of the brain
and skull there could be in encephaly
which lead to extreme retroflexion of
the head when the posterior half of the
neural tube fails to form then there are
defects like open spina bifida or let's
say closed spina bifida all these neural
tube defects are associated with low
level of vitamin B12 and folic acid in
the diet during pregnancy
watch the full video to learn more about
this